joining us now fox news legal analyst
greg jarrett former florida attorney
general pam bondi pam let's get your
take on the legal aspects of this um
there are certain rules that must apply
in a courtroom hearsay evidence is not
admissible for example
withholding exculpatory evidence
that is not acceptable either in a
courtroom
both seem to be acceptable here your
thoughts on both those issues
well first sean that's why people don't
trust congress because of show trials
just like this just what we experienced
in impeachment one and two this is
continuing on you know the um the
committee the select unselect committee
they didn't want to hear these witnesses
because they don't want the truth and
you know they put on this young woman in
her 20s who had been unemployed for over
a year
she reached out to me because she was
very excited she was moving to palm
beach to work for the president she
loved president trump well after the
election she loved him she did i have a
report tonight that she worked for
president trump in in the d.c uh
post-president office
post president she reached out to me
because she reached out to me sean
because she was looking for a place to
live in florida she was very excited
this is a young 20 something year old
did not have financial resources had not
been employed and was excited about
moving to palm beach then her
contemporaries
told the president that she could not be
trusted she was a leaker when she was in
the white house and she didn't get to go
to palm beach she reached out to me
again and she was very upset i didn't
understand why people would say that
about her
the woman i saw yesterday on the stand
was not the same woman now i understand
she was well rehearsed
and in a court of law she would have
been cross-examined were you promised
something for your testimony a job money
did you receive immunity for getting on
the witness stand
so much more how do you recall every
detail every
detail if she worked for donald trump we
we should know that if if there was any
other financial uh
transactions we should know that too
uh i heard the exact same things you had
heard uh greg jarrah from a legal
standpoint your take on all this
if a story sounds too fantastic or
outrageous to be true it's usually not
true that's especially the case when
information such as hutchinson's has
been laundered through several
individuals at bare minimum this is
triple hearsay it's probably quadruple
here's a guy told a guy who told me and
now i'm telling you the committee
hearsay is inadmissible a double hearsay
is a joke triple hearsay is a farce
anything beyond that you need to get
your head examined
but there's nobody on this committee
because it is highly partisan
to ask any challenging or penetrating
questions on cross-examination for
example isn't it true
ms hutchinson you weren't inside that
suv with the president you didn't see
what happened you didn't hear what
happened so you really have no idea
what occurred as for her other
allegations
statements she allegedly heard from him
wait a minute isn't it true you just
said that you were in the general
vicinity and you overheard the
statements to the effect of isn't it
true
you don't know precisely what we said
that would be a decent cross-examination
how did they ignore the donald trump
according to four out of the five people
in the room the fifth person was general
milly i've not been able to interview
him but someone close to him did assure
me that in fact conversations about the
safety of the capitol did come up
between him and president trump the fact
that the president authorized
guard troops in the days leading up to
the sixth
why didn't they tell that would be
exculpatory wouldn't it wouldn't that
destroy the entire narrative this
committee is trying to push on the
american people pam yep
yes it would sean and and as greg said
none of that would have been admissible
and if and if this is a show trial for
the american public that's one thing
that's what they've done since donald
trump has been in office but if this is
a a cue to merrick garland to prosecute
donald trump none of this would be
admissible merrick garland knows that
the justice department knows this it's
all hearsay and now that these secret
service agents are coming forward too
saying didn't happen did not happen we
want to testify we should have been
heard earlier we weren't now that they
have that her credibility is shot
nothing
that she could say could be true that no
one would trust it anymore
20 seconds greg the exculpatory evidence
about the troops being authorized by the
president
yeah absolutely any responsible
committee uh would have
investigated that one other thing about
liz cheney she could have just picked up
the phone and talked to the people who
actually saw and heard what happened and
would have been told according to fox
reporting that it's all untrue maybe she
already knew it was untrue which means
she was hiding
exculpatory evidence from congress and
the american public i i hope they sent
out preservation letters for every
person on that committee and every
staffer on that committee because there
will be a new congress in november well
next january thank you both hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else